ROAD.
MINNESOTA COMING OFF A LOSS IN
VEGAS ON THURSDAY  PENALTIES.
HE HAS THAT ENERGYRE BOUNCING O
WALL. HARTMAN, WHO IS RED HOT.
HE HAD THEIR ONLY GOAL HLINE, N
EBERLE.
NOW WENNBERG TIES IT UP IN FRONT
OF HIS OWNLARSSON.
HE WILL CUSHION IT DOWN DEEP.
MERRILL C BLOCKED.
EXCELLENT WLOK.
ATTACKING IT WAS WENNBERG.
ANOTHER SHOT TIC MINNESOTA.
OUT IN FRONT. SOUCY.
THROWS A NICE BY NICO AND WILL
DROP IT OFF FOR DONSKOI.
PERIOD?
>> J.T.: I EXPECT SEATTLE TO TRY
TO GET MRES.
REM PITLICK NOW HAS TWO GOALS IN
QUICK MOVE TO THEON-TWO WITH JA.
HE WILL STOP. AGAIN.
IT IS PITLICK FOR THE THIRD
TIME.
HE HAS A
GOES TO THE BACKHAND QUICK.
ALIGHLIGHT OF THE NIGHT FOR
JEREMY LAUZON AND HARTMAN IN
FRONT.
I'M NOT SURE WHOSE STICK IT WEN.
HE TRIES TO GO OVER THENBERG.
AS MINNESOTA GOT ALL THE WAY E
PERIOD.
THE FINAL FRAME, HERE IS
MARCUS JOHANSSON H H CIRCLE THE
IT.
LAY IT ALONG FOR McCANN.
IN FRONT OF TALBOT AND THERE'S A
MAD SCRAMBLE IN FRONT OF THE GE.
LAUZON, THIS WAY FOR FREE.
FOLIGNO, JUST WIDE.
STURM WILL GET TOO STARTED WITH
FOUR FORWARDS ON THE ICE.
IT IS JUST A PUCK BATTLE THE
GOAL.
TRY THIS SIDE TO THE SLOT YOU G.
NO, IT MADE IT IN!  TALBOT.
HASN'T HAD TOO MANY GOOD GRADE A